hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
once again I've been stalking those pro
fortnight players and trying to see the
behaviors they use to get the upper edge
in battle the setups they utilize to
farm efficiently and the tricks they
practice to become fortnight gods here's
100 pro tips currently used by those
people lucky enough to be paid to play
video games but first things first I
need you to smash the like button
subscribe we've 12volts accounts and
follow my best mate Dave on Twitter oh
and my grandma on Instagram
I'm only kidding there you be you if you
like something fantastic if you don't
it's fine to 100 pro tips let's go let's
start with a shopping cart or the
trolley depending on where you are in
the world when running from the storm
take one with you you can jump in the
back and heal on the move it's extremely
useful in duo's it's even better as one
person can heal while the other one
pushes as we all know teamwork makes the
dream work the shopping cart can be
forced to go faster with certain weapons
the minigun works like a dream
but the LMG and the rocket launcher have
similar effects when running from the
storm are rotating over to another area
of interest if you can spare the bullets
jump in a shopping cart and blush your
way to your destination shopping cats
can also negate fall damage not always
though it depends on your landing skills
but if you don't have the materials to
descend from a mountain top or a high
hill jump in and ride it out
it's risky so only you can decide if
it's worth the hassle but if you learn
to London all four wheels it's the
quickest and most effective way to get
down if you have the skills you can use
a shopping cart to negate a little fall
damage so if you're a four five or six
tiles high trying to jump into the back
of a shopping cart
it won't stop all the hurt but it will
stop you from dying now on to uses for
the pyramid tile you most likely never
use a great way to get inside windows
such as a tilted towers or the football
stadium is to use this little blighter
and then crouch to go through without it
it can be a bit of a struggle to get
inside
if you don't like the pyramid tile why
not switch it into a Down ramp for ease
of descending after build battles in
fact another great use for the down ramp
is by adding a jump pad to get
additional
distances it works so damn well to get
away from the storm and even better to
completely surprise other players if you
find yourself with downed comrades but
you need to escape use that pyramid ramp
and jump add technique this will allow
your buddy to crawl to safety too and
come on it looks bloody amazing too
going back to the original pyramid
setting it's actually possible to use it
in battle if an enemy builds above you
you can cap their movement with a
pyramid if you're skilled enough you can
turn this into a trap it takes practice
but if you're quick enough you can do
this this is quite an oldie but remember
you can throw a pyramid over a fallen
Ally and then keep fighting to build on
that I tend to throw down multiple to
put the opposition off completely so
anyone wanting to thirst your friend
will need to be very attentive it's like
a magic trick which one is he under if
you're in a sky base or a building on a
platform above the enemy think about
using both a floor tile and a pyramid
for additional support the opposition
will try to shoot you down but the added
pyramid gives double support allowing
you to get a shot off
jump cut away or run back and restore
the broken pieces when you find yourself
boxed up against a spammer above you use
the pyramid in unison with a floor tile
we all know that the occasional bullet
gets through so doubling up will really
help and when they go to reload edit out
and fight or reclaim the high ground the
pyramid can also be your best friend
when crossing gloop lake making a bridge
of pyramids makes your harder target to
hit and offers cover it needed if you
need to save materials when crossing
loot lake try using the jump ramp
technique here's what you're gonna do
whilst running build two ramps and jump
from the top and jump twice more before
starting a sequence again if done
correctly you won't lose any speed in
the water and you'll also be a very
difficult target to hit here's running
versus the jump jump technique they are
identical in time have you ever needed
to cross loot lake diagonally well
you'll know it can be a huge drain on
your resources well if you have the time
to edit the pyramid structure you can
change it into this monstrosity and
tightrope across loop lake oh and
remember the shopping cart minigun
technique from earlier it only bloody
well works
water too let's quickly talk about skins
we know there's no advantage to battle
pass or purchase skins but there is the
guitar I wear makes me super easy to
spot in Sniper battles the cuddle team
leader Zack uses has an oversized head
and is bright pink - again much easier
to see and be spotted we also tested
fling stealthily with the pink bunnies
and it was bloody impossible and that by
the way is where the hype bunnies were
born so a tip is to use a skin which
reflects your playstyle he can even go
full default and surprise your enemies
with your skill let's move on to farming
by now we all tend to leave 50 HP on
trees in the later game I don't know
about you but I tend to knock down a
huge hulking tree with one swing because
someone's already been here before me
well did you know that when holding a
weapon you can see the health of the
tree from a much farther distance away
than an axe after realizing that I
didn't make that mistake again how long
does it take to open a bloody llama
takes fricking Yong's doesn't it well be
aware that you can destroy the llama
anywhere you'd like to get the loot use
your pickaxe or any weapon to open the
goodies sooner in a group scenario it's
like a llama slaughter do you remember
the old ax counseling technique for
speed harvesting we try to quickly reset
our character's position so they could
swing their axe quicker well it's back
again it's much easier on PC but it is
possible on console too to achieve this
we're going to use the wave emote it
does work with other remotes but the
wave is far superior while swinging your
axe quickly email the wave and continue
swinging again this will give you an
extra swing every two swipes it's too
much effort for me to learn so here is
active G using it let's move on to
building and a general statement first
use your traps more often I bet you
finish the game multiple times and find
you have seven or more traps in your
possession I find that popping a trap
when ramping can act as a great trick
mine are indicated that someone is
behind you
regardless of the distance and audio cue
can be heard if the trap hits someone
allowing you to get the drop on them you
actually find that now traps have
received a buff you'll get more kills
than you'd expect in battle something as
simple as placing a trap in your base
will deter others from pushing while
they reanalyze their options that extra
split second could give you the upper
hand at some point in the game you'll
lose the high ground that be boxed in
try to practice these two wallets you
may be thinking to yourself just use a
door but doors take a split second to
open and also give away your position by
the sound they make by using these
specific edits you can re-engage much
quicker and using a doll when you do
breakout practice this ramp building
technique to reclaim the high ground
breakout ramp above and below do a 180
and run back over your fault due to the
inclusion of spam weapons like the
minigun and the light machine gun a new
wall push technique was created instead
of simply ramping to an opponent or
adding a wall the new technique adds
flaws for extra resilience to hundreds
of bullets to give you the ultimate
rushing protection build ramps followed
by walls followed by floors you you get
the idea to gain the high ground in the
fastest way possible
whip out your bounce pads and use this
technique jump ad from the ground but
remember to build walls on your way up
as your velocity slows down build
another floor and start the action again
bouncer spam walls floor you'll be on
top in no time but we want your
structure is extremely weak so don't
stay there too long should you need the
high ground as fast as possible but you
don't have jump pads try this is ultra
simple ramp floor ramp flaw rinse repeat
it's best to attach this to your enemies
structure for support but due to the
speed of this you can have the high
ground in no time at all and to go one
more step further than this you can use
that pyramid and switch it to a ramp
again and link them together to save
mats and climb criminally fast you know
that moment your structure is destroyed
and you inevitably fall to your death
keep in mind that the jump pads negate
all fall damage if your structure is
being knocked down you have a little bit
more time before it reaches you so take
out your bouncer and escape from certain
death if you're lucky enough to win a
fight in the sky there's a method you
can use to get to the ground
ASAP fall backwards from the edge of
your structure while spamming walls
every three floors also create either a
ramp or a floor and then rinse and
repeat in note
go back on the ground unscathed if you
require more ways to get down try
throwing down a pot abort and aiming for
those tires if you really want to show
off jump on that shopping cart but again
I I can't do it and if your skill level
is high enough use a pulse nade to
prevent your death you'll need to throw
it just as your character gets to the
top of their jump let's move on to
fights if you have to pick an enemy do
so on your right hand side all
characters are right-handed in fortnight
so the viewing angle on the right is far
superior when planning a shot as players
are becoming more savvy it's important
to try and keep a level playing field
I'm sure you've noticed the head
glitches who find the perfect angle to
sit and seemingly shoot through their
bloody bases epic I'm trying to rectify
this but it's still possible to do in
this day and age if you want to know a
mess and I'll show you one at the end of
the video at this point I'll just say
stay vigilant when this is eradicated
though with the best practice we'll be
lining up a shot whilst crouch and then
standing up to shoot and immediately
crouching again this makes you near
impossible to hit do you use auto run at
all I personally hate it but I do use it
in squads and duo's it ultimately allows
you to sort your inventory whilst moving
with the team if someone needs heels or
bullets drop them on the go oh here's a
good one
it's actually possible to reload
shotguns whilst running simply jump
reload switch weapons once you land
again just repeat the process you'll
reload one shell each jump and keep
running at full speed I want to talk
about cheap and easy kills but before we
get to that let's just do a few general
things impulse needs are great for
knocking enemies from heights but they
are also even better at allowing you to
catch up with your teammates without
asking them to stop similarly they're
great for escaping the storm I'm sure
99% of people know this but I still have
to tell people when I do random squads
campfires stack stand in the middle of
them to heal ridiculously quickly if you
have the battle pass use the limited
time mode to do your challenges if you
hate pistols but they are required to
complete part of your battle fast jump
into the limited time mode without
hurting your stats or forcing you to
play away you don't feel comfortable
with but you never know that gun you
want ignored may be your favourite after
all another battle path suggestion if
you need to eliminate enemies with a
certain
weapon use a duo our squad match and
once you've knocked an enemy finish them
with the weapon you require this way it
won't force a complete change from your
usual tactics first your accuracy is a
very big thing in fortnight at the
moment but which gun attains it the
quickest just in case you don't know
standing still for a moment will change
the reticle on screen once it does this
it means the next bullet will be a
hundred percent in that spot the blue
won't take over during our checks the
best gun for immediate accuracy is the
SMG shortly followed by the revolver the
one which took the most time in our
setup was the burst rifle and of course
some guns don't have it at all like the
dual pistols here's a silly one but if
you're feeling cocky it's pretty good
use a jump pad and Launchpad together to
create a speed parachute remember to
make a tunnel to channel the energy
though this way you'll have an instant
speed boost when parachuting finally
let's look at dirty stinking cheating
ways to get kills don't worry they're
all legit methods my personal favorite
is something I use when I have to go to
the toilet mid game I'm getting older
right my bladder isn't what it used to
be create a face full of traps then add
a roof but block the roof with your head
so it looks fully constructed but
actually it's non-existent now wait for
someone to walk over it and they'll fall
straight to their death
if that's not a dirty enough tactic for
you
you can hide traps outside the tunnels
in dusty divots your enemy wants heat
coming this area may be changing soon so
keep an eye out for other areas to use
this for example the trucks around the
island here's the easiest way to head
glitch edit the pyramid into this
monstrosity is the one we used earlier
to cross the lake now slowly crawl up
the ramp until you can shoot through it
this will protect your dome and make you
a dirty stinking cheater a dirty dirty
stinking cheater enjoy this one will be
taken out soon but it's possible to add
a trap on top of a roof tile and somehow
it appears underneath spam the build and
place buttons to achieve this dirty move
finally a note to console players we all
know that using a mouse and keyboard on
console is a dirtiest cheating method
you can legitimately do on console but
did you know there is another cheap
method which isn't seen as such a dirty
move a pro controller and currently
using a scuff impact and oh my goodness
it's like legit cheating I'll make a
video explaining it next week but
basically the extra paddles give a huge
advantage and your thumbs don't move off
the sticks right I'm getting sidetracked
and this video is getting ridiculously
long so I'm going to split the 100 tips
across two videos so I can keep them
quite short and I'm completely sure
you're already becoming bored to tears
from my voice so expect another 50 pro
tips coming very very soon I'm Adam from
Playstation grenades and just so I can
be a click beta like everybody else I'm
giving away free ebooks all you have to
do is follow my uncle on Grindr remember
to follow my granny on Instagram she
loves a good be box giveaway I imagine
from PlayStation granade it's been an
absolute pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]